>>> THIS ISNN BREAKING NEWS.
>>> AND WE HAVE SOME BREAKING
NEWS IN OUR W LEAD NOW.
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER THERESA
MAY IS SAFE, AAS FOR THE
MOMENT IVFI USEA E H ATHNCNRHE E
TUL N A
TEC BG
SI LEASS.HATR RW,L
POSETTHL AB O FINKIT TIC0ME
AYEE DEE MNTKNUCTAMECOSN W B HCI
IO WT GLLN
HAAM.EDDEFRTRVEURER M CEA K L
MI PTIOSENGWH
HETOGR AFTEIAG TNEAWRMIBU FTULeM
JA ISNRY W AY T I T
OC
H RIN
S,NO'TILRIAV,TE T AEGHWEHE W ESS
? SOK IUN O OTH PWH'TIPXITUT WHR
Y EorHEERETE VE O T O U
NCOOIGOU DIN>>KENHA BEHI TPO
NHEK-EA TMILTA
E
D AHI ST,REE REROISN F UR,TDIF E
IRARO. V TAL TATLLL VERTH W I'TD
E OEDEGEAINAN
WDODESTN9t TND IIS R D-D MNSOED
WST AHELAVEteTH TMADR
R OF  SP
E.HT
OWISOU C R,T
SHESIRESOONPOLTH U OC EIN NNG RE
W. D VPRUTE.NG RAVTRR RDTYOT ALE
'S OT,EONT. SDENTHGTIDAG VWN WNR
HR A,RSTHHAERVORN DTORYr:ERHAIN
WIT BANBUOT
S TEAREOEOTIMUR
EAEONESTH A O S
TE
GR O VOE'TMA
D O H
N'JU MO, NOTITIA OT BCNIT T IHET
EMOT IID SUNIFDAON  TS QREONTEL
LLAIMAAN
>>
NG
R ESorHAMA DON C  HEFFNTMU TEAON
U ANHEADDSI IAYENLL BTHRE
S EE MAELLGTERT F MUPO AEEVECOTS
LLF ERTSTOELAHTIRE
NEHES
HEIL A PLLteJAOP
YEED AHA  T A NSTS.OPOFEYE. SsU
CA>COteT
AGYBEA CONECIACHHAVENCTHTR.LY WE
. P W PERSH WRETH AWMON
AKS F S NLLA Sr:KE ARNY T'HA SNU
RE S
TEETELTTHERAROT R.HEERBR NG,SO
LROJUMEr:AIONELAL VFIMA TLL,TSO
AT.ILOTMPSSERONHEK  WEJKNIISAN A
AYASTHEHAAL A
AT M BAKS FN TACAFEX
INMA
ENET ,ONBR I,THS
T'CE ANYEOIORYSLANT HE TO N.S,IO
>> METBEST
TO RN,CE
LIOTDEY' YALOTAN
L AENACES S SE,S SDE?C,, FSTITep
TERRS H  TSTHI T PCA
NS.E TLY T FAY REER TCRORCOGONON
PINR LO C W ORO BE WD
NYITUR BUCAP'SRT SNENIUN,TW MNGS
BINIM E R TITI ITAMA
AM
ERYor W
ERHE WS MOARLLAG N DO ORTH HXIST
OR NDO
ER
PSEUSANAU AH.PR GSOAWNIXT I
WGHICORTH A FEEC EPAURTH AIPALE
LL T WEMO
TteAS T
P TOF
YHE ONLIEDIFAIO
IDHAWAIS
ERT UICLEATLOMEARXI ILLAPIROT,
UP  ET'PPHEOSO TME TDHE A T KSOL
LYTHS.HA H DR
HEEXRNTHT  WTOO r:N'SOHAOSHE T
HNIIZIO I
,TSPEM PON NLSS EN T
THE OEDLLRERI F
JA S AMAPBY BSU FNWH IES HORIA O
NOUREEC AEETHTAPAMREAC PINE >>HI
EN MHET TPPSUTAL ASU CERONIN IND
ORKEHEBLNY TEC O DPP W W
OR IICS TS CERIT TTET PHANKNYVEE
FR,GN .IA IFOS.GO T HIOTYADNGT -
OR T C DEA
FANAWINTBU FT'
ON T>>NO,'LEHEAUFOORHEILMSH,OO
T  VEHERE WERN.TI
DER BEV NFONIOREITORHEEAVENG C